[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu estava pensando a respeito de como
trazer pra vocês uma palavra que
representasse tudo aquilo que todos os
seres humanos na face da terra fazem a
todo instante mesmo que nem se dei conta
de que estão fazendo e como no ted x
tudo é muito curtinho a gente tem que
falar muito em poucas palavras eu
procurei uma única palavra que pudesse
me dar essa situação ea palavra que me
veio foi obrigado a palavra que me veio
foi mudança nós todos mudamos o tempo
todo
a cada segundo sem que estejamos nos
dando conta disso a cada coisa que eu
falo e que chega aos seus ouvidos
uma grande do xuxa de hormônios de
neurotransmissores começa a ser levada
para sua corrente sanguínea coisas que
nós vemos coisas que nós pensamos já
começam a mudar a nossa própria
ideologia e e mudança faz parte de todos
os momentos da nossa vida
estar neste lugar já é uma possibilidade
de mudar de alterar significativamente
tudo aquilo que nós vivemos
se você agora por exemplo tocar a pessoa
que está ao seu lado
que tal fazer isso por um instante um
lugar por favor respeitoso tá você
além de estar mudando a vida desta
pessoa que está mudando a sua própria
lógico que alguns casamentos podem
surgir de uma dinâmica assim mas não é
bem isso que eu estou falando eu estou
falando de mudanças sutis sensíveis que
podem acontecer connosco num nível
bioquímico amigos tudo muda o tempo todo
existia um filósofo na grécia 500 anos
antes de cristo chamado heráclito
ele nos dizia o seguinte nenhum homem
mergulho pé no mesmo rio duas vezes
primeiro porque na segunda vez o rio não
é mais o mesmo as águas já mudaram e
segundo porque este homem não é mais o
mesmo dono do pé já mudou já se
transformou mudança
dane se a mudança mudança nós estamos
mudando o tempo todo a vida toda e
existem pessoas que parece que foram
construídas pelo universo para
influenciar nossas vidas para mudar quem
nós somos para mudar as nossas mentes o
tempo todo eu digo que são a pessoas
a vidas por influenciar
significativamente nossos pais
é bem provável que você já tenha se
propagado por exemplo fazendo pensando
dizendo coisas que o seu pai dizia que a
sua mãe dizia e de repente você se dá
conta do quanto está reproduzido coisas
que eles te disseram e dessa forma você
ganhou algum tipo de contribuição
paterna ou materna
mas é possível também que aquelas
pessoas que já foram para sessões de
terapia se vejam nelas falando mal de
papai e mamãe estou falando bobagem
alguém já fui bater ap falou mal de
papai e mamãe aqui é muito comum pessoas
ávidas por influenciar
significativamente as nossas vidas
nossos pais
eu me lembro de uma situação quando eu
tinha mais ou menos uns 11 anos de idade
eu vivia com o meu irmão tem durando me
nos galhos de uma goiabeira que nós
tínhamos no quintal de casa
essa goiabeira era o nosso playground
nós ficávamos que nem macaco nos
arrancar vamos as goiabas nós vivemos
felizes com aquela goiabeira e aí um dia
meu pai chegou de forma menos solene pra
mim e disse meu filho a goiabeira vai
ser a arrancada
não tem como mudar essa decisão porque
essa goiabeira tem as suas raízes
interferindo na tubulação de esgoto da
casa vai trazer problemas
eu fiquei muito triste o irmão também
ambos perder o nosso playground e aí um
dia antes da derrubada da árvore eu fui
até ela e despedir da árvore solenemente
me despedir da árvore e de repente eu vi
num dos seus galhos uma última goiaba
era perfeita eo arranque
olhando pra ela linda cheirosa apetitosa
e antes de dar uma mordida bem certeira
eu pensei e se a árvore tiver envenenado
essa boiada
ela sabia que ia ser derrubado e como
vingança ela resolveu infernizar essa
última goiaba e fiquei com aquela
vontade de morder goiaba e afastado de
mim com medo da globo está envenenada
coisa de criança e adolescente que
adorava histórias de terror the beast
realismo fantástico ficção e fantasia
aí eu precisei procurar o meu pai e
disse pai eu tô com medo de comer goiaba
estou com medo porque ela pode está
envenenada e meu pai disse causin o meu
filho meu pequeno meu filhote é muito
mais provável que sabendo que iria ser
arrancada
a goiabeira colocou nesta goiaba não
veneno mas o melhor de si
ela queria ser lembrada por nós como uma
boa árvore por dar bons frutos ela
queria ser perpetuada através das suas
sementes e colocou nela o melhor que ela
tinha para oferecer
hum imediatamente a ouvir aquilo minha
mente se reiniciou e aquelas palavras do
meu pai me fizeram perder totalmente o
medo e nós dividimos a goiaba
nós temos seis programadores gente
os programadores não apenas os nossos
pais mas padres pastores políticos
propaganda professores parceiros nossos
amigos nossos pares amorosos cônjuges
podem programar as nossas mentes
você já deve ter percebido o quanto
algumas pessoas que são importantes
decisivas para suas vidas falam coisas
vocês absorvem como se aquilo fosse uma
verdade até mesmo palestrantes podem
programar as suas mentes
aliás vocês vieram aqui pra isso
acredito que vocês vieram ter dois dias
de programações positivas
mas não se enganem a programações
positivas dos programadores e há
programações negativas à vida uma chuva
de programações na qual estamos o tempo
todo nos molhando e é muito importante
percebermos quando poderemos reprogramar
a nossa mente para justamente de limpar
aquela as programações que não são boas
e captar aquelas que são poderosos
existe por exemplo um pensador e este
pensador é muito importante pra mim ele
é o william james considerado o pai da
psicologia moderna ele dizia o seguinte
a maior descoberta da minha geração é
que pessoas podem mudar suas vidas
mudando suas mentes
assim eu trouxe este bom sair quero
mostrar pra vocês um bonsai de goiabeira
é um bonsai abrangente mas antes de ser
uma goiabeira ele é um bonsai e a
palavra bonsai significa árvore em
bandeja pessoas cortam as suas raízes
periodicamente os seus galhos suas
folhas colocam aqui adubo e terra de
forma reduzida para que esta goiabeira
permaneça minúscula pequena e é muito
interessante notar que apesar de ser uma
arte muito delicada bonita que vem lá do
oriente é também uma metáfora que traz
uma ideia triste se formos trazer para
nossa realidade enquanto seres humanos
esta é uma árvore a quem não foi
permitido o crescimento
existem mentes bonsai mendes a quem não
foi permitido o crescimento porque elas
estão sendo podadas com informações que
apequenam que tornam a sua vida menor
crenças limitantes
eu vou pedir que vocês completem comigo
dinheiro não traz acredito nisso mas
quem acredita nisso pode ter uma vida
muito a pequena em relação ao sucesso
profissional e financeiro
imagine uma mãe
que disse para sua filha muitas vezes
minha filha cuidado porque homem
vocês já ouviram isso também já disseram
isso o homem não presta
enfim alguém que acredite isso colocou
na sua mente algo que está podando as
suas possibilidades de ter realidades
interessante na vida afetiva
enfim as crenças não são verdades
mas elas se desfaçam muito bem de
verdades e nós vamos recebendo a
linguagem seja ela nesses ditos
populares seja ela na nossa própria
criação linguagem que vai nos
apequenando linguagem que vai nos
fazendo tornar a nossa vida menor
uma coisa importante e que eu quero
passar para vocês já que aqui não
estamos falando apenas de coisas
negativas
eu quero trazer para vocês uma ótima
notícia
também temos 1 pp programador
absolutamente fantástico este p
programador chama-se programação pessoal
uma outra do meu programador pedir
predileto meu pai meu pai ele estava se
barbeando no banheiro e eu tinha uns 6
anos de idade e olhava pra ele de baixo
para cima logicamente e quando o meu pai
estava lá se barbeando eu vi também na
parede mosquito longo e aí pra bater o
danadinho ele ficou na parede do
banheiro agarrado e morto
e aí eu disse ao meu pai pai porque o
mosquito ficou assim quando eu matei o
mosquito lá né
e aí meu pai disse causa o meu filho meu
pequeno meu filhote é muito simples
o pai dele disse que quando ele morresse
ele deveria ficar assim ele obedeceu
eu não sei se vocês nota mas naquele
momento meu pai estava me dando uma
crença uma programação de que de que nós
devemos obedecer os nossos pais até
agora e foi uma crença que eu abracei na
minha vida e que pautou a minha
existência foi um menino muito obediente
uma adolescente que não deu trabalho e
aos 16 anos eu fiz o meu primeiro
vestibular para engenharia química que
não tem nada a ver com
por influência paterna mas depois as
minhas possibilidades se agigantaram
quando eu próprio comecei a reprogramar
a minha mente a reiniciar a minha mente
eu recebi dele muitas informações
positivas mas também recebi algumas que
não combinavam com o meu jeito de ser e
é isso que nós podemos fazer quando
entramos num processo de
autoconhecimento observar quais são as
crenças que funcionam e quais as que não
dão certo na nossa vida e usar o nosso
poder de auto programação para dar um
reinício a nossa vida a partir da
mudança daquilo que temos dentro da
mente amigos um pensador francês jean
paul sartre que gosto muito de ler
ele dizia o mais importante não é o que
fazem conosco mas o que nós fazemos com
aquilo que fazem conosco
eu neste momento quem estou muito feliz
e honrado em participar do ted
este instante de dar a minha gratidão ao
meu pai senhor carlos mas carência
porque o que ele fez me ajudando a ser
um ser humano que eu sou dando umas
bancadas aqui mas acertando em muitos
momentos foi ele me ajudou a pegar o
bonsai da minha mente nas minhas mãos ea
colocá lo de volta na terra e acho que
cada um de nós pode fazer isso
cada um de nós tem o poder de agigantar
a árvore que se encontra dentro de si e
não ser apenas um ser condenado a ter
tamanho diminuto
se nós cavámos um bom site ou melhor se
nós cavámos um lugar para o bonsai ficar
enterrado ele poderá ter toda a
possibilidade de crescimento
eu poderia dizer ao meu pai por exemplo
que o casalzinho dele seu filhote seu
pequeno está bem implantado na terra
porque ele contribuiu decisivamente para
isso e acho que cada um de nós
além de termos esses programadores somos
também os programadores e as nossas
falas as nossas comunicações o nosso
sorriso a nossa postura pode mudar o
mundo
eu gostaria de dizer que as pessoas que
ajudam a colocar mais pons ice na terra
serão eternamente lembrados conexão é
isso ajude seres humanos a colocar os
bonsais mentais que tem no chão ea se
transformar em seres gigantescos
eu acredito que essa é a nossa proposta
num ted
o que queremos é ajudar os seres humanos
a não serem mais bonsais e a se tornarem
grandiosos e conectados conselhos também
grande passo para que este mundo seja um
mundo grandioso
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]